Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
That was a bit of a surprising start.
Good morning, Mococo-chan!
BAU BAU!
Can you hear BGM?
Oh, it seems like maybe we don't have it for today.
Well, let's go into introductions.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 23rd episode!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Today started with a bit of a start.
23 Episode 7.
Every time it's a little bit different.
For the first time Ruffians, let's explain a little bit about FUWAMOCO Morning.
FUWAMOCO Morning is...
It's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO, and it's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You never know what's going to happen with a new morning call.
I heard that there's some really exciting things happening this weekend, right Moco-chan?
Right!
We have Mumei-senpai!
Mumei-senpai is going to be having her 3D showcase tomorrow!
Ruffians!
You excited?
Of course.
FUWAMOCO is too!
We're looking forward to seeing what Mumei-senpai is going to do.
I'm excited to think, will Mumei-senpai have a drawing segment?
Or maybe teach us more about civilization?
Singing and dancing!
Hopefully!
I think so.
Yeah, you know, I always look forward to the singing and dancing part, but I'm actually really excited for maybe what sort of place she brings us to.
Just like Fauna-senpai's home course, and Kronii-senpai's worst days.
I really like that.
The forest is so pretty when it's glowing at night, right?
I'm excited.
I'm really looking forward to seeing Mumei-senpai move around, dance around,
Go freely and freely.
Spread her wings.
No horror.
I really hope that there's no horror segment.
No horror segment.
Really cute.
Only smiles.
BAU BAU!
Right.
There's actually some bad news, Ruffians.
Got bad news.
Bad news.
Already.
You know, the morning is a bit different this morning, and now there's bad news.
Yeah.
Well, last FUWAMOCO Morning, we told you about the good news that Papa Papa fixed that lightbulb that wouldn't work properly in the kitchen, right?
Right, the lightbulb?
You remember, right, Ruffians?
It was just a really super simple fix, just a little flick.
It was all good, right?
Remember?
Well, there's bad news about that.
It suddenly stopped working!
It's misbehaving again.
Yeah.
We didn't break it, it broke itself.
We did it!
Yeah.
You know, Papapabi fixed it so easily, so we thought that we could just do that too, but... We even got out the staff stool.
No matter what, it wouldn't work.
I tried and tried and tried, but... So... No luck.
Once again, I'll be back to chopping veggies and cooking food in the dark for a little bit.
Just a bit.
Yeah.
At least until we're able to get the courage to change the lightbulb.
BAU BAU.
But we're strong!
Strong, right?
I don't know what it is.
It's really scary changing a lightbulb.
You have to go up high.
I don't want to drop it.
Right?
And then the screwdriver goes like... Right?
Well, Ruffians!
We have an update!
Important update.
I guess it's sort of important.
We have a Pero Update!
Ruffians, you might know, but yesterday we went to go find Pero in the backrooms of Fubuki-senpai, right?
Fubuki-senpai!
And thanks to Fubuki-senpai, we were actually able to complete it and make it out of there.
We made it out!
We really didn't think that would be possible, right, Moco-chan?
No!
No, I really didn't think- Oh, spoilers, spoilers!
Whoops.
But did you believe in us, Ruffians?
But Ruki-senpai believed in us.
But did the Ruffians believe in us?
Quiz?
No.
No!
I don't blame you, it's okay.
You didn't really think it would happen.
I didn't know.
Yeah, but... The thing about that is... We didn't find Pero, though.
Yeah, nothing.
There was just, you know, there were a few things here and there that I thought might have been him for a moment, but it was just my imagination.
You know the little raincoat that ran by?
It sort of looked round and fluffy, so I thought maybe, maybe it could be him.
I did look around the corner for a bit.
Right?
And like there'd be the floaty things that kind of looked white and fuzzy and I thought, oh!
But it wasn't.
It wasn't him.
You know, it's a bit frustrating since we went all the way for him.
Twice!
Right, Moco-chan?
Ungrateful.
Whatever.
It's fun.
What's more important, I think, than finding Pero is that we're able to find a new friend in there.
In the back room.
Fubuki-senpai!
Not the monster.
Not that friend, no.
But you know, we're really really happy to be shown around, and so gently too.
Fubuki-senpai was so nice, always praising us.
You know, sometimes I thought that Fubuki-senpai might try to tease us at the beginning, but I realized that wouldn't be the case.
At first I was like...
Well, this is Fubuki-seppa's home, right?
Yeah.
So, but... Yeah.
It was okay.
But it was a nice ASMR!
I don't know if that's really the best... Not a good idea.
Yeah.
We're really happy to play together with Fubuki-senpai.
We talked about more horror games and that sounds good for training.
Not good for my heart.
I think we would really like to be able to chat freely together.
Unfortunately, we couldn't really talk that much.
Right?
We'd get in trouble otherwise.
Can't have it find us.
As for Pero, though... Moco-chan, what now?
If he isn't in the backrooms, then where is he?
Actually, it does look like a Ruffian spotted him, but... It's not great, Moco-chan.
Where is he now?
You spotted on Mars?
I guess in his own words, you know, he's a great Peroncino, right?
So maybe this is normal for him to even travel into space too.
That's pretty impressive.
But he's on his own now.
We can't go into space.
Even if you know, even if Pero was in trouble, even if he was crying, maybe not crying.
Demon Guard Dogs don't go into space.
We belong on Earth.
At least two paws on the ground at all times.
Probably for the best.
But, you know, I'm not really sure what Pero could be looking for.
Why is he even going out into space right now?
What does he want to find?
Right.
What is there to find?
Is there anything to find in space?
I don't have a good feeling about this, Moco-chan.
He's on his own.
Thank you, Ruffians, for sharing an update with us.
It's good to know that he's no longer in the backrooms, but...
Frustrating.
We worked hard.
What?
Ruffians, you saw it, right?
You know that we worked hard, right?
Right?
You know, Ruffians, if you see him again soon, please let us know as soon as you can with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
Well, it's good that we got up to FUWAMOCO-chan.
Yeah, I guess.
It's good to have information.
Information's always good, yeah.
It's a bit disappointing, but oh well.
We've had another...
Misunderstanding.
This is a misunderstanding that maybe we should share.
Try to clear up.
You know, we feel like maybe after our last Adventures of Cookie and Cream stream, that maybe some Ruffians may have misunderstood something.
You know, we can get really heated, right?
Like, especially during the canoe level, and the level after that, and then the merry-go-round!
And the flying machine too!
There was a lot!
And you know what?
It may have seemed like we were a bit rough on each other, but you know what?
Please don't misunderstand, okay?
We're always, always nice to each other.
Even if we're mean to each other.
Because, you know... It makes sense!
If we're mean to each other, it means we're nice to each other.
That's what the Ruffians know.
It's because we're so close, okay?
So we don't even need to think about...
That is being mean to each other, you know?
Get it, ruffians?
Yeah, we're just being silly, okay?
Right, right, yeah.
So if you ever think, ah, FUWAMOCO is being really rough to each other today, just know that we're good with each other, and we're only like this because we're so comfortable and close, you know?
Don't worry, okay?
Yeah, some little squabbling won't get between us, okay?
And you, Ruffians!
When you have things like that in your lives where you feel like a fight or something could hurt your relationship with other people who are important to you too, I would like you to think to yourself, is it worth it to potentially hurt my relationship with this person over this?
Is that important?
Is it worth being mad or upset over it?
That's all.
BAU BAU!
No more misunderstanding, right?
We're never angry.
BAU BAU!
It gets better!
It gets better, right?
No... Moco-chan... Moco-chan... We have a... a confession.
I really don't think we need to... to do this, you know?
We don't need to share this with the ruffians.
This is too personal.
It's unnecessary.
Moco-chan... I really have to!
You have to share.
You have to share!
I think it's probably best to confess.
You know it.
I really don't like Moco-chan.
I think it's best.
After FUWAMOCO Mornings, you know it.
Sometimes.
We go back to sleep.
It wasn't part of the plan though, okay?
It was never our intention.
Right.
You understand, right?
Right, Ruffians?
The intention is to start the day together.
And that we get going with a little push.
Right, right.
From the Ruffians.
From each other.
We get the Ruffians a little push, but... We're sorry.
I know we're supposed to start the day on the right paw!
And we haven't really been keeping our paw out of the deal, you know.
This whole time, Ruffians, you've been giving us a push, but you didn't really know that that push was actually towards bed.
Oops.
But we've been strong a lot of days, just some nights.
And a lot of nights.
By the time we finish the stream things, you know, it's really late and there's other things that we kind of need to get done to come in.
Before you know it, there's only a few hours left before FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah, it's frustrating.
It's embarrassing.
Ruffians, don't look at us differently, okay?
You get it, right?
It's okay, right?
We'll do our best to stay awake after FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
We're really not too good with naps.
No, I don't like naps.
No, we're big sleep people.
We just can't do the short sleeper sort of things like some of our senpai can.
I wish we could, but we like our big sleep.
Yeah, we're just not built the same, okay?
Demon Guard Dogs need a good sleep too.
Your image has been broken!
Please, don't sleep yet.
Don't think differently, okay?
Ruffians, you don't go back to sleep either, right?
Right.
Don't.
And if it's late where you are, do it.
It's important for you to sleep if it's late where you are, but if it's early where you are, gotta get going.
That's the point of FUWAMOCO Morning, you know?
I don't feel better.
Thanks Moco-chan, this was all your fault.
You're welcome, you're welcome.
Let's just go Moco-chan, forget, forget.
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
A good doggy would take my mind off of that.
Doggie of the Day is...
Oh!
Look at this doggy!
So fluffy!
And that amazing sleep he must be getting.
I'm not envious.
I don't know, this face kinda looks like he's definitely around 6 hours into a good rest.
Getting the Rama sleep, Rama cycle going on.
It doesn't look like we have a name though.
Moco-chan is with us!
What should we name him?
That's a good face.
A good smiley sleepy face.
Well, I feel like it looks like the tongue could just fall out and stay out too.
Ruffians, do you have any ideas?
Borgor?
What?
Borgon.
Nemu!
Cute!
Nebosuke!
Okay, let's go with those.
Which one?
Both.
There's three.
There's Borgon, Nemu, and Nebosuke.
Nebosuke.
Okay, Nebosuke!
Well, maybe Nebosuke, maybe it's not so much of a BAU BAU this time, but how does Nebosuke snore then?
There's definitely a mouth open here, so I know that Nobosuke likes to sleep with the mouth open.
Wait, how does he snore?
Or how does he BAU BAU?
How does he snore?
No BAU BAU.
Oh, of course.
Sounds a bit angry.
It's like that.
I see Nebosuke-san exactly like that.
Does that sound right?
Nebosuke is very fluffy.
And I kinda think the more fluff, the better a friend to help you fall asleep is.
What about fuzz?
Fuzz?
Not as good.
But you know, actually, we gotta be careful looking at the face.
Or maybe we'll start to want to go back to sleep.
But you know, good doggy, good ruff.
But no more naps for today.
Our day is starting.
No more napping.
Uh-uh.
Day is starting.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
That didn't really help us take our mind off the question just now, did we?
Ruff!
Where are we going?
Hoi!
Wow!
Rainbow!
Pretty!
That's great that you're able to put yourself outside on such a rainy and cold day.
It looks like it was well worth it being able to see such a gorgeous rainbow in that one!
Moco-chan, we always want to go on walks together, but it's rough when it's nasty, right?
I don't want to get wet.
Yeah, and then it's just like cloudy, and cold, and maybe windy.
It should go outside by... But you know, we're really glad you're able to get yourself going outside despite that.
I feel like it's so rare to see a good rainbow nowadays too.
It's sort of magical, exciting, you know?
But rainbow or not, a good walk always lives the spirit.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing your walk with us.
Let's go outside even if it's cold, okay?
Yeah, even if we're sleepy too.
BAU BAU!
Our question of the day.
What kind of question do we have?
We have... De-den!
If you didn't become Demon Guard Dogs, what other career would you two have studied for?
I can't imagine Fuwawa being an accountant.
Oh, you can!
Ruffians, would you like me to be your accountant?
Numbers.
Fuwawa will take care of the numbers for you.
You're good!
Yes, yes.
Please no.
Well, if you said please, then... I guess.
Well, for us, you know, we both feel that being Demon Guard Dogs is our calling, you know?
And protecting your smile is our job.
We both feel very dedicated to... Dedication.
I feel really lucky to be able to do this and it's really fun too!
You're smiling!
But actually, originally me, me, Fuwawa, I wanted to get into business.
Yeah, I wanted to be my own boss.
Do something really cool, you know.
Flower boss.
Like wear those pantsuits, you know.
I mean business.
But, Ruffians, as you might kinda know, I'm terrible at math.
So, that's actually why I studied so, so, so, so hard.
Yeah, it took up all of my time.
There was a lot of late nights and even more tears too.
And that was really so just so I could be able to study business.
And I did get pretty far!
Actually, I got really, really, really far.
I was just one class away, but then I couldn't pass it.
And no matter how much I studied, I just didn't understand the concepts.
So then everyone told me I should find another dream.
Yeah.
But, you know what?
I don't regret it because now I'm here with you.
And I'm able to do this, so... I'm happy, but I don't want other people to dissuade you from your dreams, okay?
Just keep at it!
But please also remember what's best for you, Ruffians, too.
As for me, Mococo...
I don't know what I'd be doing.
If I didn't have your smile to protect, I feel like, knowing me, I'd probably just get locked up in a cell again.
But, I study too, okay?
I study really, really hard.
Even math.
I don't know what for, but I did, okay?
You did, you did.
Yeah.
Okay?
So don't just think that Fuwawa is the only one that studied, because I studied hard too!
Yeah.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the question!
Remember, Ruffians, we're always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, for Doggie of the Day, questions, and your walks.
We're really happy if you could submit more and share your everyday with us, you know?
All you want!
Do it!
Right!
Send us lots of pictures of your doggy, you know?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
As for our next stream...
We have...de-den!
We're going back on our journey in The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time!
It's time to switch on the N64, Moco-chan.
Switch on.
Switch on the N64.
Not the switch.
Yeah.
Yeah, the switch has a button.
The N64 has a switch and it makes a nice sound like the poka.
Why does the switch have a button and the N64 have a switch?
You'll have to take it up with the Nintendo, Miki.
I will, I will!
But it's been a little while since our last journey in Zelda.
But we were able to help the Gorons, you know, reach the Yummy Rocks again.
We got through Dodongo's Cavern.
Alright, so...
I guess that means that this time we're off again on a journey, and we're looking for our next place to go, right?
I'm not too sure where we're headed, but I'm excited.
BAU BAU!
Let's take another peek at our schedule.
Well, tomorrow, right before Mumei-senpai's 3D showcase, we'll be having another FUWAMOCO Rock'n'Roll Party!
And, like we said during our collab with Fubuki-senpai, this time, the theme is Japanese oldies!
Yeah, we're singing only songs from the Showa period, so that's songs that are all before the 1990s.
Yeah.
Maybe there's a lot of Ruffians that haven't really listened to all these before.
There's a lot of really really cool ones.
I don't know what it's gonna be.
City Pop.
I don't know if it counts as City Pop.
We talked to Nerissa about this before.
But we're gonna be seeing a bunch of our favorites.
So if you really like it, you can join us for a bit of a nostalgic, but maybe not nostalgic, but nostalgic still.
FUWAMOCO Rock'n'Roll Party!
We'll also be finishing off this weekend with a classic and a rather short visual novel from the makers of Clannad.
Planetarian!
We'd love it if you could join us and get nice and comfy and cozy.
Comfy and cozy.
Nice way to end the weekend, right?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us for today!
We hope you had another good week of mornings with us, FUWAMOCO!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
GM!
BAU BAU!
Party Panda!
Bunari!
BAU BAU!
Jifusu!
Not Lux!
BAU BAU!
Skyline!
Jun!
BAU BAU!
Rice-sama!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!